foreign
[Music]
hello I'm Alexander Rose the executive
director here at long now tonight I'll
be joined by our speaker Dr Kate darling
who joins us from the MIT media lab in
Boston
for several years she's been studying
the way humans and computers and AI
interact and today she's going to be
talking to us about a potentially new
paradigm about the way we might think
about that interaction she's also going
to be talking about the way this is
presented in her book The New Breed
welcome Dr Kate darling
thank you so much Xander it is so great
to be here
so I love robots I love robots more than
I love spiked lemonade but I have a
three and a half year old and a newborn
baby at home and ever since I had kids
people will say something to me they'll
say Kate you must find it so interesting
to watch your children's brains develop
and watch them learn about the world
given that you study robots
now I love this I think it's a great
conversation starter it's wonderful that
people ask this question given that they
know that I love robots so much but I am
here today to tell you both why we so
automatically and instinctively compare
robots to ourselves to humans and also
why I think that that's the wrong way to
think about robots and artificial
intelligence as we move into the future
now another question I get a lot is what
is a robot there's actually no Universal
definition of the word robot
people have different definitions
depending on the field that they come
from and people have different images in
their minds of what the word robot
actually is I operate with the same
definition as most roboticists which is
a robot is a physical thing so not a I
or a bot it has to be physical it can
sense the world it can take in
information think about what to do next
based on what it has sensed about the
world and then it can act on its
environment again now that sounds pretty
good but when you drill down on that
definition it gets a little fuzzy at the
edges I remember when I first got to MIT
and I was so excited to see the truly
Cutting Edge work being done in robotics
you know the robots that we've been told
over and over again are gonna take
everyone's jobs and take over the world
and I quickly discovered that there's a
massive discrepancy between the public
perception of where the world is in
robotics and where we actually are so
from what I've seen trust me for most
robots if you ever feel threatened you
can just dump a bucket of water over
them and you should be absolutely fine
now that's not to say that we shouldn't
be thinking about what robots mean for
the future of work for the future of
humanity that's something that I think
about a lot I just come at it from a
slightly different perspective on our
future and that starts with a unique
aspect of robots that I'm especially
interested in which is our
self-projection
for example something that I think is
fascinating is the fact that there's a
Japanese manufacturing company that will
have its employees do exercises in the
morning to warm up their bodies for
their day on the assembly line
and this company which also has robots
working in the factory will have their
robots do the same exercises with their
arms in order to be perceived more like
colleagues and less as machines
isn't that a little bit weird
or I think it's interesting that when
Boston Dynamics released the following
video
everyone in robotics watched this video
and said wow the robot didn't fall over
but then there were quite a lot of other
people who watched this who expressed
more negative emotions about what was
happening in the video and it actually
got to the point where Peta the animal
rights organization was getting so many
phone calls that they had to issue a
press statement
now Peta didn't really care much about
this they said they weren't going to
lose any sleep over this because it
wasn't a real dog
but I'm interested in this I am
interested in the fact that despite all
knowledge to the contrary people will
consciously or subconsciously treat
robots like living things
now I was at a conference a couple of
years ago getting a spiked lemonade at
the bar and I met this guy
let's call him Scott because that was
his name
and Scott asked me what I was interested
in and I said I'm interested in the fact
that people consciously or
subconsciously treat robots like living
things
and Scott said ah
I don't buy it
we talked for a long time over lemonade
I could not convince him so Scott's
perspective was this this is a
generational issue he said
sure maybe our generation we grew up
with Star Wars maybe we will reflexively
apologize when we stumble over a
delivery robot on the sidewalk maybe
we'll name all of our robots but newer
Generations that grow up with this
technology everywhere they're going to
treat robots just like any other device
now like I said I could not convince
Scott of this as we parted ways but look
sure part of this is the influence of
Science Fiction and pop culture and part
of it is the novelty of the technology
so in 2015 when this hitchhiking robot
got beat up in Philadelphia
people were really upset about it but
they might have been upset about it
because they had never seen a
hitchhiking robot before and they really
got into that narrative
but there's a piece to our perception of
robots that goes deeper than that and
that is our anthropomorphism we have
this inherent tendency to project
human-like traits qualities emotions
onto non-humans we do this especially to
animals people will project emotions
onto their pets that may or may not
actually be there in fact science shows
often that we get it completely wrong
and that the animals don't have the
emotions that we believe that they do
but it's not just living things we will
project onto things that are created in
the image of something lifelike like a
stuffed animal we will see faces and
random objects or car headlights we do
this from a very very early age one of
the first things that infants learn to
recognize is faces and they don't even
have to be real faces they can just be
black and white images on a screen so
this is very ingrained in us we do this
in order to interpret the world around
us and make sense of our world and
relate to anything around us and one of
the things things that we also respond
very strongly to is movement
studies show that our brains are
constantly scanning our environments and
trying to separate things into objects
and agents and that makes sense
evolutionarily because we had to watch
out for the agents in the past
but what's happening now is we have this
new kind of object that moves like an
agent and that tricks our brains into
projecting intent and life onto any of
this movement that we can't quite
anticipate what it's going to do next
and you see this happen even with the
most simple robots take the Roomba
vacuum cleaner
not the most sophisticated robot in the
world it's basically just a disc that
moves around your floor to clean it but
the fact that it that it's moving around
on its own will cause people to name the
Roomba over 80 percent of roombas have
names
I don't know the statistics for your
regular handheld Dyson I guarantee you
they're lower people will feel bad for
the Roomba when it gets stuck somewhere
I was visiting the company that makes
the Roomba a few years ago and they had
all these stories of people who would
send in their roombas for repair and
they would turn down the offer of a
brand new replacement vacuum saying no
we want you to fix Meryl sweep and send
her back to us now a more extreme
example of this is military robots there
have been these bomb disposal units that
the United States military has used in
Iraq and Afghanistan they are designed
to let soldiers hang back out of Harm's
Way a lot of them are just remote
controlled and only partially autonomous
but soldiers will treat them like pets
they gave them names they gave them
Medals of Honor they would hold funerals
with gun salutes for them when they
couldn't be repaired there are even some
stories of soldiers risking their lives
to save the robots on the battlefield
that they didn't want to leave behind
Peter Singer writes about this in his
book wired for war
now the interesting thing here is that
these robots like the Roomba are not
designed to look like anything special
they're basically just sticks on Treads
and they're already having this effect
and that brings me to the element of
design that can enhance this even
further
now there are a lot of robots out there
that move in very biologically inspired
ways
the reason for this is often practical
so Boston Dynamics is a company that
makes very biologically inspired robots
the reason that they do this is
practical animals have evolved over
billions of years to be really efficient
in navigating different terrains so it
makes sense to borrow from that Anatomy
when we are trying to design robot
Locomotion but it's also very very
difficult to watch these robots move
around and not feel like they have some
sort of agency
now at the end of that conference where
I met my lemonade friend Scott we
actually bumped into each other again
this was this Robotics and space
conference there were a lot of demos and
Scott said that he had seen a demo that
made him think more about this
and the thing he had seen was this very
biologically inspired dragonfly robot so
it had wings and it could fly around
um and it looked like a dragonfly and
the thing that he noticed was not the
robot but the people in the room
watching the robot he said that they
were totally transfixed they could not
take their eyes off of this thing that
was buzzing around their heads and he
said you know what Kate maybe you're
right maybe we are built this way
but I still don't buy it and I said oh
come on man but we shook hands and we
decided that the next few decades are
going to be very very interesting to
watch because this is something that can
be designed intentionally and that's
what social robotics is all about
social robots are robots that are
intentionally designed to mimic cues
movements sounds whatever that people
automatically subconsciously associate
with states of mind
and this works really well
um I first got really into this topic
when I bought a toy called a pleo it's a
baby dinosaur robot that came out in
2007.
so this is the pleo
the pleo is a very cool toy that I
initially bought because it has all
these Cool Motors and touch sensors and
an infrared camera in the snout and it
mimics lifelike Behavior really well and
one of the things it has is a tilt
sensor so it'll know what direction it's
facing
I thought this was really cool and I
would show it off to my friends and I
would tell my friends to hold it up by
the tail because this is what happens
when you hold the pleo up by the tail
[Applause]
[Music]
it mimics pain and distress
so I would show this off to my friends
and
some of our friends held it up for a
really long time and watched it squirm
and that started to make me
uncomfortable I realized I would ask
people to put it back down and say
that's enough put him back down and then
I would pet the robot to make it stop
crying and that was really interesting
because I knew exactly how the robot
worked and I still felt compelled to
comfort it
so that sparked a curiosity in me and
fast forward a few years I did a
workshop with my friend Hannis gosselt
at a conference called Lyft in Geneva we
took five of these baby dinosaur robots
we gave them to five groups of people we
had each group name their robot and play
with it interact with it we had them do
a little fashion show with the robots
where they dress them up in pipe
cleaners and construction paper just so
that we could personify them a little
and then after about 45 minutes to an
hour we unveiled a hammer and a hatchet
and a knife and we told them to torture
and kill the robots
now this turned out to be pretty
dramatic we obviously wanted it to be
dramatic but it turned out to be more
dramatic than we expected it to be we
had initially thought okay there's
probably going to be a split of people
in the room some people are going to say
oh so what it's just a robot and some
people are going to have more of a
problem with the violence and we wanted
to ratchet up the violence and see how
the split in the room changed and
instead everyone just absolutely refused
to even hit the baby dinosaur robots we
finally had to threaten to destroy all
of the robots unless someone took a
hatchet to one of them
and this poor guy volunteered and we all
stood in a circle around him
and he brought the hatchet down on the
on the robot's neck and people kind of
winced and looked away
and then there was this half joking half
serious moment of silence in the room
for the Fallen robot
so that was a really interesting day now
this wasn't science this was not a
scientific experiment this was not a
controlled setting there were a lot of
social dynamics but it inspired some
later research that I did at MIT with my
colleagues Cynthia Brazil and
polashnandi and for This research
instead of using really cute evocative
baby dinosaurs we used something much
more simple we used hex bugs which are
these toys that move around like insects
in a lifelike way but they're very basic
and simple and we had people come into
the lab and smash them with mallets and
we wanted to know two things so we
wanted to know would people hesitate
more to hit the hex bugs if like we do
so often with robots we give them a name
and a back story so we say this is Frank
Frank's favorite color is red he likes
to play and then the second thing we
wanted to know was how people's
hesitation to hit the hex bugs related
to their natural tendencies for empathy
so we did psychological empathy testing
with people and we found that people who
scored low on empathic concern for
others in general
they didn't seem to care much about
Frank they would just hit Frank and
people who scored higher on empathic
concern they would hesitate more or
sometimes even refuse to hit the hex
bugs
so that was just a little study but it
is part of a large and growing body of
research in human robot interaction that
shows that we respond genuinely to the
cues that these machines give us and we
respond even if we know perfectly well
that none of this is real
okay so why does this matter
I think it matters because what's
happening right now all over the world
is that robots are moving from being
kind of behind the scenes in factories
manufacturing behind walls and cages and
they're coming into shared spaces spaces
where they are interacting with people
workplaces households public areas so we
have these machines that can sense and
think and make autonomous decisions and
learn and they're not alive and they
can't feel but people feel differently
about them than they do about other
devices and that is such an important
thing to understand as we start to
integrate this technology that people
treat it differently
and in some ways this is even really
useful we are already seeing some pretty
cool applications in health and
education that specifically rely on
people treating a robot like a living
thing or like a social actor on them
even developing an emotional connection
to a robot so for example there's some
very intriguing research on autistic
children and using robots as a tool and
therapy and the robots in this context
aren't used as a replacement for a
therapist or a parent it the robots are
actually facilitating conversations
between the child and the adult in the
room and the researchers aren't quite
sure why robots are so useful in this
context but they think it's because for
these kids the robot is clearly
something social for any of us a robot
we will treat it like something social
but the kids also understand that the
robot doesn't come with all the baggage
of humans and so it can actually
facilitate some of the conversation that
we want to be having now it's not just
in this context there are also a lot of
studies being run on using robots in
education using robots to help kids be
more curious about different aspects of
learning and again this is not to
replace teachers but rather to be used
as a supplemental additional tool in a
classroom setting and then there's
therapy robots like the Paro baby seal
that's used in nursing homes and with
dementia patients this one has been
around for a while it's a very very cute
baby harp seal robot it responds to your
touch it makes these little movements
and sounds it's pretty simple but it has
quite an effect on the people who use it
it lowers their blood pressure it can
calm them it gives them a sense of
nurturing something in a context where
their lives have been reduced to being
taken care of by others
now the first response that I often get
to Paro is oh my gosh Kate I can't
believe that we are living in a dystopia
where we give people robots instead of
human care
I think that that's a very
um Justified thing to say because we
shouldn't be replacing human caretakers
with robots that's a terrible idea but
here's where I want to point out what I
think is a huge problem in a lot of our
conversations around robots in our
casual conversations in our news media
even among roboticists themselves and
that is that we often subconsciously
compare robots to humans and artificial
intelligence to human intelligence now
of course we do this given everything
that I've just told you about how we
anthropomorphize robots and project
ourselves onto them
but we do it constantly we do it in our
stock photo images if you Google image
search artificial intelligence you get a
bunch of images of human brains and
humanoid robots and human heads but we
do this also in our conversations about
robots replacing jobs one to one we do
this in our conversations about
intelligence like comparing my
children's brains to to AI but this
analogy does not make any sense at all
so on the one hand we already have
robots that are smarter than people we
have robots that can do endless
calculations that can beat us at chess
at go at Jeopardy that can recognize
patterns and data that we would never
see
and then on the other hand
people are also much much smarter than
machines
it used to be that if you asked Apple's
Voice Assistant Siri to call you an
ambulance she would literally call you
an ambulance because she didn't
understand the context now of course
Apple fixed this once it became known
but they probably had to fix it by hand
because
Siri even today if you try to have a
conversation with her you will probably
give up pretty quickly that's not to say
that machines aren't smart it's not to
say that they're not becoming smarter is
to say that machines understand and see
and learn about the world differently
than we do
and so the question to me is not can we
eventually at some point in the future
recreate human intelligence the question
to me is why would we want to do that in
the first place
when we can create something different
so it shouldn't be our goal to recreate
ourselves it's actually more useful to
create something that's supplemental
and I actually just wrote a book called
The New Breed that tries to challenge
and break this mold of subconsciously
thinking of robots like humans by
offering a different analogy
this is an analogy that is familiar to
us that acknowledges that robots are
different from toasters in that they can
make their own decisions and learn about
the world and it's one that changes some
of these conversations and what I think
are pretty important ways
so if we come back to the baby seal
robot the Paro
parro is not designed to replace human
caregivers what Paro is designed to
replace is animal therapy in contexts
where we can't use real animals for
reasons of health and hygiene and safety
but we can use the robot and it works
because people will consistently treat
the robot more like an animal than a
device
and it's not just in the social robotics
context if you think about it throughout
history we've used animals for work for
Weaponry for companionship we
domesticated them because their skill
sets are different from ours not because
they do what we do because they're
different and that's useful we've used
oxen to plow our fields for Millennia
we've used horses to travel the world in
new ways here is the original hobby
photography drone in the early 1900s
there was a German pharmacist who was
using pigeons to deliver medicine which
is something we're starting to do with
drones in remote locations today and one
day he had the wild idea to put cameras
on the pigeons to see if they could take
aerial photographs and it turns out they
could and of course later the CIA
adopted this to create spy pigeons but
pigeons also delivered mail for
thousands of years letting us
communicate with each other in totally
new ways
now animals not only have physical
abilities but also sensing abilities
that are way better than ours and
Incredibly useful
this for example is an official United
States Navy echolocation device
in the 60s and 70s both the United
States and the Soviet navies started
Marine Mammal training programs because
marine mammals have amazing echolocation
systems
so they use them to detect lost
underwater equipment and mines there's
some rumors that they strapped harpoons
to them and made them into weapons as
well but the United States also used
both robots and dolphins in the Gulf
Wars to look for mines and in fact the
dolphin program is still in place
because even though they've tried to
phase out the Dolphins and replace them
with robots the Dolphins are still in
many ways better than the technology
here's also the original sensory
equipment used in the mines the canary
in the coal mine and I could go on and
on right there are so many examples of
how we were using robots today in roles
that we've previously used animals in
but the point that I want to make is not
that animals and robots are the same the
point that I want to make is that moving
away from this constant quasi-human
comparison opens our minds to new
possibilities it's a really useful
thought exercise it helps challenge the
idea that robots in a AI can will or
should replace people
the true potential of Robotics and
artificial intelligence is not to
recreate what we already have it's for
us to partner with these Technologies
and what we're trying to achieve
I think this human comparison also lends
itself to some rhetoric that's pretty
misleading
so over the past five decades you've
probably seen some headlines that look
like this
no jobs blame the robots
well that headline would be a little
more accurate if it was no jobs blame
company decisions driven by unbridled
corporate capitalism
not such a pithy headline but more
accurate because it's not the robots
taking the jobs right thinking of robots
as quasi-humans giving them this agency
in our language really lends itself to a
determinism about our future and about
the automation of Labor when in reality
we have choices we don't like to see
this but we have choices we could be
using technology to help people do a
better job rather than trying to
automate them away
if you look at warehouse workers today
it's kind of like that Charlie Chaplin
movie modern times where companies have
automated as much of the process as they
can and so they're treating the human
workers like a part of the machine they
have scam guns that count down the
seconds between tasks they make them do
things that they are clearly hoping that
they can eventually automate once the
technology gets better but that's not
the only way to think about or handle
human labor like a replaceable commodity
so take for example the United States
patent and trademark office I know that
a lot of patent and trademark offices
are dealing with the problem that you
have patent examiners that get tons of
applications on their desk they need to
decide whether any invention is new
enough to Warrant patent protection and
so technically they have to sift through
all of the world's information in order
to make that determination which is
impossible and so you know one of the
things that the United States Patent
Trademark Office could have done which I
have seen companies do is they could
have said hmm I wonder if we could train
Artificial Intelligence on you know the
historic data that we have and have it
make determinations that are you know
have a slightly better hit rate than the
examiners because even if it's just
slightly better than the very poor job
that we're doing right now then we can
get rid of all these people and not have
to pay them their salaries
no instead what they said was how can we
use this technology to help our people
do a better job and so they started
looking for ways to use AI to surface
some of the prior art that the examiners
wouldn't have found on their own and
then letting the humans do what they do
best which is make that judgment call
that determination
so how can we use robots to help people
do a better job rather than replace them
how can we use robots to help people be
more productive to leverage what people
are good at and enjoy doing while
automating the things that robots are
good at which tend to be the uncreative
dirty dangerous or dull things that
people don't like doing anyway
now unfortunately while employers could
be thinking creatively about supporting
workers whether that's in their current
jobs or supporting them through
transitions because this still requires
a lot of disruption to our current way
of doing things
these choices are driven by a broader
political and economic system that sets
short-term corporate profit incentives
and does treat workers like a commodity
and that is a really really difficult
thing to address and change but that's
the conversation we should be having
instead of this the robots are coming
for our jobs technological determinism
that I see everywhere
now another area where I think we can
and need to shift the conversation is
when we talk about law specifically
responsibility for harm I have seen too
many lawyers argue that we are currently
at a unique moment in history because we
are developing machines that can make
their own decisions some of which not
even the creators or users could
anticipate and to deal with the problem
a lot of the proposed Solutions are
along the lines of can we hold the
robots themselves accountable either by
programming them with certain baked in
rules or ethics or the EU has even had a
proposal to create an electronic
personhood to be able to make the
machines themselves responsible now this
is not completely out of left field
because we've created personhood for
corporations and other non-humans but I
think we don't talk enough currently
about how there is legal precedent for
unanticipated autonomous Behavior we've
had to deal with the question of
responsibility for animal cause harm
ever since since the beginning of laws
known to humankind that dealt with what
happens if your Ox wanders off into the
street and Gores somebody unexpectedly
whose fault is that who has to pay for
that and different societies had
different answers depending on their
culture but the point is we have this
whole Smorgasbord of ways that we have
dealt with autonomously caused harm in
the past and we should be drawing on
some of that when we think about this in
the future again the point is not that
robots and animals are the same the
point is that thinking about this
analogy gives us some different options
and most importantly it helps us start
from a different place because when you
compare robots to animals it suddenly
feels very different to argue that they
should be accountable we don't expect
animals to abide by our rules and moral
codes a zoo can't let the tiger wander
on the zoo freely and then when I eat
someone point to the tiger and say oh
well you know we couldn't how could we
anticipate that we trained it to be
really nice we did our our best but
we're already seeing corporations and
governments try to distance themselves
from responsibility and blame the
algorithms in their rhetoric when
something goes wrong and that worries me
because in the past some of our
analogies for technology have actually
influenced some of our law and policy so
two researchers Richards and smart
called the human robot comparison the
Android fallacy and I think that that is
happening here and we need to be very
aware of it
now I do not think that it is possible
to get rid of our anthropomorphism I do
think we need to be like I said
appropriately aware of it and we need to
guide it where we can for example when
we're talking about liability for
example when we're talking about the
future of work
but I think what it also means is that
we're going to see certain things happen
as robots become more part of our daily
lives for example socially
if you think about it throughout history
we've treated most animals like tools
and products and some animals as
companions
I think it's entirely plausible that
we're going to start doing the same
thing with robots treat most of them
like tools and products and some of them
like our companions
now we know what Scott would say to this
and here's what I want to say to Scott
look maybe you're right
maybe once robots are ubiquitous we will
treat them just like any other device
but I just don't buy it and I think that
the research on human robot interaction
is not only interesting but important I
think that what's Most Fascinating to me
about this research is that it's
teaching us more about ourselves it's
teaching us about human psychology
empathy how we relate to others
if we look at the history of animal
rights for example it doesn't really
match the philosophical reasons that a
lot of us believe in like preventing
suffering our actual history shows that
we care way more about preventing
certain types of human behavior or
protecting the animals that we have an
emotional or a cultural relationship to
when it comes to animals we don't truly
care as much about inherent criteria
like Consciousness or suffering even
though we think that we do and we want
to many of us and we've kind of ignored
that hypocrisy but what human robot
interaction research can do is hold up a
mirror and make us confront some
uncomfortable truths about ourselves
one of which may be that we care more
about a fluffy baby seal robot than a
living breathing slimy slug
now that's not to say that we can't
shift our Behavior if we don't like
being this way but it requires seeing it
acknowledging our social Tendencies
helps us better navigate technology
integration and it's also helping us see
I think some of the real issues that we
may be facing in the near future because
what keeps me up at night is not robot
takeovers it's privacy and data security
it's the ways that robots could be used
to manipulate people not just for their
own benefit in healthcare and education
but for someone else's benefit so
setting aside some of our moral panic
and our determinism about the future
really helps us be more clear-eyed about
our challenges and about our choices it
helps us think outside of the box it
helps us lean into the positives and it
helps us intentionally build technology
with the goal of benefiting people
and if we can do that then I for one
am excited to welcome our new robot
partners and to work together to shape a
future that supports human flourishing
thank you very much
thank you so much Kate that was really
great and I would like to welcome you on
live from your home in Boston
hi
good to see you
good to see you too
um that was fantastic and I think this
way of thinking about robotics is a much
more helpful Paradigm um than the one
that we're all used to and you know I've
built robots for the TV show BattleBots
and there's there's and you know these
robots get destroyed there is often this
kind of funny empathy thing that happens
um every from everywhere from the
builders to the audience and you know
I've seen kids you know run up to me
we're like how could you let that happen
it's a kind of a funny moment because
it's the purpose is the destruction of
the robots uh but I think I like this a
lot better um one I think at the
beginning of your talk you had some of
the video of the dancing robots and I
think you know this is this thing that
um you know robotics companies love to
make demos that make their robots seem
more
lifelike
um yet those are you know when you look
at it in contrast to the the DARPA Grand
Challenge and an unscripted environment
where they're falling down trying to
open a door you realize that there's a
really big difference like the robots
are generally not listening to the music
that are dancing right
um but why do you suppose robotics
companies are trying to change you know
they're trying to change this perception
even though it I think in some cases
works against them in the in the world
yeah that's a good question well I I
think they're kind of Trapped because
they need to raise money right so they
have to they have to you know put forth
a product that
um you know looks useful or cool and or
or at least a vision of what the product
will be in the near future near enough
future for investors to want to invest
in that right so if your company you
very much have to follow the money
um but yeah I you know I I do want to
say uh Boston Dynamics has a really bad
reputation but I know that they take
great pride in their videos actually
being accurate uh in in the sense that
they are not
um what you see in the video actually
happened like it's not you know sped up
or staged in in a weird way what I think
the problem is is that in people's minds
if a robot can do one thing then it can
do other things too uh we have this idea
of intelligence as being general
intelligence like our own and and skills
being more General and that's what you
see the DARPA challenge that as soon as
you take a robot and have it try to do
multiple tasks it will fail because
we're just not there yet we can only
create these single task devices and so
you know the companies create these cool
videos and people have their own
interpretations of oh well if the robot
can dance and it can also you know open
the door and Escape or come and you know
kill my family in our sleep uh which is
not quite accurate right and that's the
part that I think is interesting well
that while the following the money in
one way but where when public perception
becomes the robots are dangerous or
potentially dangerous and it's kind of
working against them um so it's I guess
it remains to be seen what that the
smart way to to do this is
um yeah I was after hearing your talk I
was reminded of uh I was driving through
San Francisco and it was going by a park
and there was this new robotic lawnmower
that was
going down um mowing this lawn of the
park but then like 20 feet behind it is
this guy operating the robot which I
thought was really odd right because
they've now taken a job that was a blue
collar entry-level job that I was guy
riding the mower and replaced it with
probably someone that cost four times as
much per hour who's now a robot
technician driving the robot 40 feet
behind it I was very like they're not
going to just unleash you know robotic
lawnmower robots in parks in San
Francisco around humans so clearly
there's this human thing that where and
I've seen this over and over again where
actually robotics isn't being introduced
really just mixed jobs that were entry
level or blue collar into robotics
engineer jobs which are kind of more
difficult to fill and more expensive and
I wonder what your thoughts are on on
this kind of the way that you know
robots are kind of being moved into our
lives I think for a technological demo
reason instead of the truly saving of
time and money reason
oh that's so well put I think that is
true that we are seeing a lot of robots
as you know technological demos or just
you know PR uh to draws for attention
and people because they can't actually
replace jobs I do want to push back a
little bit on the idea that it always
goes in the direction of well now
someone operating the robot is a higher
skilled worker because you also have the
case where you know you have the
self-checkout things at grocery stores
that are always malfunctioning and you
have someone there who's performing the
labor of helping the customers navigate
you know the Technologies it's not
working properly and sometimes that is
invisible labor that doesn't even get
compensated like suddenly you you have
people doing more work or like more
annoying work that doesn't ever get seen
uh we also and I don't know if you have
been to a stop and shop on the East
Coast this is a grocery store that we
have um we have these robots named Marty
that roam the aisles that are six feet
tall and they have these googly eyes and
all the robot does is it tries to detect
hazards on the floor and then alert an
employee to come clean the hazard and so
uh you know I've I and one of my
students Daniela Depot have spent a lot
of time in Stop and Shop watching this
robot and watching it you know flag
people to come over for tiny pieces of
cilantro and watch the employees like
walk over and sigh heavily and like
press the button on the robot to make it
keep going so you know you have I I
would say the most ideal case of this uh
disruption is if you have a robot like
the lawnmower robot and then you have
the person who is previously driving the
lawnmower you train them to be able to
operate the robot and that happens
sometimes that's happened with some of
the sewer robots in India but I think
that's really what we want we want to be
able to train people so that they can
have a more fulfilling job
um and instead of either getting rid of
them and hiring someone who's higher you
know has more qualify applications or
you know having them do the horrible
cleanup work without getting compensated
um we're gonna be bringing in Kevin
Kelly one of the founders of long now in
the senior Maverick at wired and we'll
be doing that shortly but I had a great
question
um from Juan on the YouTube feed
um what do you think about the robotic
augmented experiences created to let
humans explore a darker side of their of
their own personality something like we
saw portrayed in Westworld
oh so yeah so
Westworld is
um very interesting to me because you
know I've done so much work around
violence and empathy with robots and I
think that the question of you know what
happens once we can build a theme park
where we have robots that you know we
might not have quite the same level of
Westworld but we already have robots
that can mimic pain and distress and
what if you had a theme park where
people can go and do whatever they want
to them is that something that is a
healthy outlet for violence at home a
robot that would be yeah or at home a
robot that you can just beat up I mean
it's great now you're not beating up a
human right is that is that healthy
thing that we should provide to people
or is it as someone once said to me
training your cruelty muscles and we
don't know the answer to this it's kind
of like the violence and video games
question but it's on a new level because
we are such physical creatures and this
is very visceral to us so I think it is
definitely a question worth asking and I
think it's a question that we will be
asking as these robots come more into
our lives and have more lifelike
Behavior
excellent and I welcome Kevin Kelly
hi
it's really great Kate I I think your
book is fantastic the New Breed and
um I highly recommend it
um and uh just picking off of the
previous question one thing I don't
think you got to the book in in the book
exactly but it's very related which is
um
the idea of treating robots as slaves
and I think it doesn't really affect
them but treating them as slaves would
be very corrosive for us
and and so I'm wondering I'm wondering
if you've thought about that it's not
even about being violent it's just this
idea that they are our slaves they do
whatever we said want we command them to
do this or that and so that kind of
slave
relationship might be again it may not
affect them at all
but it could be very corrosive to us and
so I think that's some of the things
you're kind of exploring in your book
about the violence other things is that
setting aside their own the robot's own
ability to apprehend us the effect is
mostly about us
I mean yeah I totally agree with you
that the question is how it affects us
and not how it affects the robots since
they you know are very far ways away
from feeling anything if ever
um the reason I can tell you the reason
why I did not really address the slavery
Topic in the book which is that I I find
that it lets you then easily fall back
into the human comparison
um and and I also find it honestly a
little bit problematic to
um compare human rights movements with
kind of the robot rights and ethical
things that I talk about because it kind
of neglects the historical and and
current contexts that we're in
um but I do think that you know the the
reason that animal rights are such a
good analogy and slavery is is useful in
some contexts but maybe not completely
is because it's it seems to be at least
clear to us on some level that you know
humans have the same capacity for
feeling pain or being conscious we might
not agree on what pain or Consciousness
is but we kind of agree that humans
generally have kind of the same
abilities for that whereas animals you
know there's a wide range of different
types of intelligence and Consciousness
and do they feel pain is it okay to eat
fish if they don't have any feelings you
know so I think that's a more accurate
comparison to the wide range of AI and
Robotics that we're going to see and the
questions that we're going to be facing
if we're talking about you know
is robot conscious does a robot deserve
you know certain treatment which robots
deserve better treatment than others I
think we're going to quickly fall back
on these
um kind of similar arguments that we've
seen in animal rights and then it's all
going to be irrelevant because we're
just going to follow our emotions anyway
right right yeah no I I think you're
introducing the idea of a better model
for us thinking about these varieties
and pluralities of artificial
intelligence is embodied into robots is
to think of them as animals either pets
or domesticated workers and
um what's interesting to me about about
your suggestion is that um
as you note in the book that once you
begin to look at our own
um ideas about animal rights we're
totally conflicted and we're completely
inconsistent I mean basically if you eat
meat and are concerned about animal
rights
you're a hypocrite right I mean in some
senses because we don't know what animal
intelligence is like we don't know what
their Consciousness is like we we don't
know so many things so it's very very
messy and at first I thought well that's
like um that's like a bug but actually
that might be
that may actually be the feature the
whole point of treating things like
these uh uh robots like animals is
because we don't know what intelligence
is in machines either we don't know what
Consciousness is we don't have any idea
and so we can take this model where it's
already messy and we don't know what
we're doing and we apply it to the
robots to help us figure out what it is
that we're thinking about so it's kind
of like a really great first step
is that kind of the thesis that is
absolutely what the third part of the
book was trying to to go for that it's
that's why this is a useful analogy
because it you know let's take a step
back from these conversations about you
know what is consciousness in Ai and and
look at you know historically how we've
dealt with animals this other being that
can sense and think and make autonomous
decisions and learn and what we've what
we've learned is we don't we don't have
any answers there either so it's a good
place to start yeah so I I have one last
question which is
um in the book you
spent a lot of time kind of talking
about the interesting history of animal
rights and their legal status and other
approaches that we've had to
companionship from the Western
perspective but it's my observation that
the people who are really going to be
deciding about these things are probably
going to be Asians
the ten times people in India and China
who are probably going to manufacture
and manufacture these and maybe even
sell them and so what have you found out
about how their views on this since they
are probably going to be the people who
maybe decide and whether they have any
different views than us
yeah I I very much focused and very much
made clear that I focused on the western
perspective in the book and that there
are many other perspectives that would
be very helpful to look at um I do like
my very limited experience with Japanese
culture has been extremely Illuminating
when it comes to how we view or could
view robots in ways other than how we
view them here in the west because
um
they're they're called I mean in in
Japan with the history of Shintoism and
treating objects uh like they have a
soul and not really distinguishing
between living things and non-living
things I think that that is one of the
reasons that
um the Japanese have tend to have a very
different attitude towards robots and
view them not so much as something
that's coming to uh I don't know
something creepy that's coming to
replace this but rather something that
they just kind of fit into society the
way that they've fit sewing needles and
rocks into society so I think that there
absolutely needs to be much more work
done and there need to be many more
voices from other cultures teaching us
again different ways of thinking about
robots and conceptualizing them in order
to move us away from this quasi-human
analogy and some of the tropes that we
so easily fall into yeah well it's great
work I highly recommend people follow up
and thank you for your fantastic talk
thanks so much thank you
that's great
um one other thing I mean I think we
have you know we have certain types of
lessons where where robots have crept
into our lives and taken over things
that actually do take a human job and it
seems to have been fine we talked a
little bit earlier about things like
washing machines and you know close
washing machines as well as
dishwashing machines where I know here
at here at our bar if the dishwasher
goes down we have to hire a human that
night to start washing dishes so it's a
it's a true replacement but
um you know what what do you think is
the reason that those robots that have
crept into our lives
um and do human tasks are seem to be we
don't seem to have empathy for them when
they don't work we hate them we don't
feel bad for them
why do you think that is
well yeah I I think it has to do with
our very messy definition of what a
robot is Right sometimes it's any new
fancy technology that has some sort of
uh like automatic can do it something
automatically is a robot um and then
once it becomes more integrated into our
lives or workplaces it becomes a tool
like a dishwasher
um and I also think it gets to our uh
you know the weird ways that we treat
some robots like they're alive and some
robots like tools and uh depending on
their function it depends a lot on the
design I talked a lot about design but
it also kind of depends on the function
so yes we've had we've had a lot of
technological disruption
and uh it's it's funny how we focus so
much on robots and artificial
intelligence as like this major
disruptor that's so different from the
other disruptors and I think that has a
lot to do with our own fears and less to
do with the technology itself yeah now
indeed it seems like there's certainly
no you know no real feelings for the
office printer when it goes down other
than hatred so
that seems to be a different type of
robot for sure
um
and uh one of the questions from the
feed from our YouTube feed from Anton
um he's asking you know how and when
should we allow robots to say no to us
is there is there an ethics of when
robots should answer no to a human
request
that's a really good question so
uh yeah so the first time I encountered
this was there was this Radiolab podcast
years ago like over 10 years ago
um and they interviewed Freedom Baird
who was a roboticist at the media lab
who way preceded me
um and she had bought a Furby and she
she carried the Furby around with her
and when it when the Furby the the old
Furby I think the new Furby too but when
they get flipped upside down they say me
no like and they start to protest so
they start to say no or they start to
tell you to do something differently
um and so she realized that that made
her feel bad and she would take the
Furby out and put it back upright and uh
so so she started thinking more about
how we react to robots
um but the yeah it's it's a question
that toy designers are already facing
like do you design a toy that says ow
that hurt me when you hit it please stop
uh or do you design it to not react and
I I think it very much depends on the
situation but it's something that we
need to be very sensitive to because you
know in some ways saying no
might even
lend itself to people than wanting to
torture it even more in some cases and
is that good are you then training
people to override consent I think we
just need to be really careful
especially when it comes to kids as to
you know how how these interactions are
are being monitored
um and how we design these toys and and
the first step is really understanding
that we do subconsciously treat them
like living things
yeah I mean obviously the asimov's Three
Laws kind of in some way cover this
right of like you know you can't train a
robot to hurt another human that's where
a robot's supposed to say no right
um so that's one of those places I'm
wondering those three laws are are
they've been kind of amazingly
useful in thinking about robots even
just in films and things like that as we
imagine our future is there is there
thoughts on more robotics laws or more
any consortiums of roboticists that are
talking about this as a broad field that
we need to you know have have good robot
laws
well to me I mean the usefulness of the
laws is the fact that Asimov showed over
and over again how they don't work right
they you know
yeah so I mean what it really what what
it illustrates is how complicated it is
to rely on the programming of the
machine to follow any kind of rules that
we give it especially if that's like an
ethical or moral code which we haven't
even agreed on as humans so it's I I
think it's useful in that sense
um but people often forget that right
they forget that really the stories are
about how the laws how laws like that
don't work and they say oh maybe we can
develop some laws like Asimov so so it's
kind of I wonder you know how he would
feel about the fact that people have
kind of taken that in the opposite
direction
right yeah well I mean I guess they're I
mean they're they're useful thought
experiments but they're kind of most
entertaining when they start getting
broken but and I but I did want to ask
this question of you know where is the
field of Robotics and Ai and talking to
themselves about ways that we're going
to do this is this uh you know you know
early on in the the biotech World there
was the asilamar conference about the
ethics of the way we're going to do
synthetic biology and I know there's
been some conferences on this but and
now there's some institutes that are
starting to talk about dangers of AI
where do you think this is kind of
fitting in and going or you know
obviously I think that's going to be
different from country to country as
well but is there is there a way we
should pay attention to or as consumers
of Robotics and AI encourage certain
types of kind of ethical discussions
that are happening in the field
absolutely and there has been a lot of
it in the past few years it's really
grown into like I'm part of this
conference called we robot that talks
about the legal and policy issues
related to robotics which is also often
related to ethical issues and um when we
started the conference 10 years ago
people thought we were Kooks right like
what are they talking about what is this
science fiction stuff and now it's like
a huge thing because uh AI ethics has
blossomed them to people are starting to
understand how important it is as a
field
um and it's so heartening to see so many
roboticists and artificial intelligence
researchers uh kind of engage with with
this and understand that it's important
I mean I see it in my workplace now
where there's been this huge shift
towards trying to incorporate more of
that I think where I still see a problem
is that there's not enough integration
of like cross-disciplinary Integra
operation
um
we don't have enough ethicists who
really know how to work with Engineers
or Engineers who know how to work with
ethicists people are starting to try to
throw people together and see what
happens but I think we're going to go
through some Growing Pains before we see
some truly interdisciplinary action on
this that we ultimately need
I agree yeah I mean I think as somebody
who's as I mentioned built robots for
for TV I've certainly had this you know
the first question out of so many
reporters mouses you know so when are
the robot overlords taking you know
taking over and you know what you
realize as of somebody who makes robots
that as you pointed out it's it doesn't
take much to defeat a robot in all those
things in almost any circumstance and so
it's it's it always seems so far from
from an experience of people who build
these things that that they're going to
take over because you spend so much time
just getting them to work for like one
or two minutes
um
it does not seem like the worry that
there's going to be a takeover
um so thank you so much for this I want
to ask you know this this book is
fantastic and it's coming out and where
are you where are you heading next with
your research and thoughts on this stuff
I've looked it although hear about what
you might be doing next while we we had
a bunch of experiments planned for the
fall and now we're waiting to see
because we are currently still in a
global pandemic uh waiting to see if
that's possible because you know my
passion is working with people and
robots and um
so but uh some of the experiments that I
have queued up are around consumer
protection and policy issues around
emotional persuasion
um through robots and also some uh just
it's we live in such an interesting time
I mean especially where you are where
robots are coming out onto the streets
uh it's so interesting to see these
robots that Engineers have developed and
like they've they they put so much
effort into like you said like just
getting them to function right and then
sometimes they just don't take into
account what happens when you put the
robot in an environment with people and
psychology and emotions come into play
um and it's so funny to watch like some
of the mistakes that are being made and
some of the successes and to understand
that human robot interaction as a field
is really important and growing in
importance as we try to integrate this
technology
yeah it is I've seen them on the street
I've seen people both help them and hurt
them uh these delivery robots on the
street so there seems to be definitely a
mixed reaction to these things well um
thank you so much for joining us and for
this talk um and I hope that at some
point we can have you here for a spiked
lemonade uh here at the interval uh we
can have this discussion further thank
you so much thank you so much for having
me
and thank you our audience uh and look
forward to having you at one of our
talks in the future
thank you
[Music]
foreign